[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a psychological thriller war
film called mine
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the movie begins with a hardened u.s
marine mike saying goodbye to a young
woman at the airport and traveling in a
helicopter to his next mission
in the next scene mike and his spotter
tommy are set up on a cliff overlooking
a desert waiting for their target to
arrive tommy is a chatterbox by nature
while mike has a more serious
disposition they notice multiple people
on foot on one side and multiple armed
vehicles on the other approaching mike's
target is a 65 year old terrorist syed
asif as tommy and the voice over the
radio try to get mike to make the hit he
realizes that the group has gathered for
a wedding and the target might be the
groom's father
matters are further complicated when the
groom and bride block the target mike is
ordered to take out the groom to get to
the target but he can't bring himself to
take an innocent life mike lies to his
command center that he lost the target
the duo are then spotted by armed men
protecting the ceremony gunfire follows
the target immediately flees while mike
and tommy are forced to retreat as armed
men start chasing them while running
they damage their gps and hide behind a
rock formation the armed men start
walking towards the rock when mike
quickly creates a clever distraction to
send them in the other direction
after evading the armed men the duo
request an evacuation but are told they
need to cross the desert in front of
them to get to a village five hours away
where they can be picked up they set out
on foot weathering sandstorms and
scorching heat tommy entertains mike
with the stories of his son back home
seeing mike silent and seemingly
troubled by something tommy forces mike
to open up mike reveals that he is
having a hard time proposing marriage to
his girlfriend jenny tommy makes fun of
him for being so scared but also gives
him advice that initially marriages can
be difficult but over time you get the
hang of it while passing through the
desert wind brings a warning sign flying
right beneath their feet mike takes the
signs seriously recalling that 33
million landmines have been buried in
the desert in the last 40 years tommy
assures him it's just a berber trick to
keep enemies away
mike is still proceeding cautiously his
mind preoccupied with the warning sign
tommy walks backwards carefree a few
yards in front of mike taking
lighthearted digs at mike for being an
overthinker
suddenly a click sound is heard and an
explosion follows
tommy had stepped on a landmine as he
goes temporarily deaf mike takes a step
towards tommy and hears another click
where his foot has just landed he
freezes in shock the sand from the blast
starts to clear out tommy has survived
the explosion but his legs below the
knees have been amputated tommy screams
and quivers in pain mike unable to move
himself struggles to calm tommy down
when nothing seems to work mike brings
up tommy's son which gives him some
motivation and he's able to inject
himself with the morphine that marines
carry in their front pocket tommy then
tries to reach his radio but the pain
again takes over him seeing his partner
in pain mike offers to take his foot off
the landmine in order to help tommy mike
speculates that perhaps the landmine he
stepped on is old and defunct
tommy warns him not to and in order to
dissuade mike he pulls out his gun and
aims it at his head he tells mike that
he must survive no matter what and
shoots himself mike helplessly screams
in grief he is stuck in the desert all
by himself unable to move
he soon gets tired of standing and gets
on one knee mike realizes he must
somehow fetch the radio lying next to
tommy several yards away he ties his
shoelace to an axe to pull the radio bag
towards himself however he learns that
the radio's battery is dead and the
spare is on tommy's body mike is
dejected but thinks of another plan he
makes a makeshift arrangement to charge
the radio using solar power mike is then
able to contact his superiors he
requests immediate evacuation but he is
told that rescue choppers can't fly to
his location because of frequent
sandstorms if it all goes well a convoy
will rescue him in about 52 hours
mike gets frustrated by the response the
major then suggests mike try digging a
ditch and jumping in it which would only
result in a non-life-threatening limb
loss
mike decides to tough it out and wait
for rescue setting a countdown on his
watch
then another massive sandstorm hits full
force he manages to wait it out without
moving from his spot
once it's over the first thing he
realizes is that the storm has brought
tommy's body and therefore the spare
battery right next to him yet the radio
has drifted too far from his reach
hours pass by mike runs out of water and
gets increasingly desperate and at times
wonders about shooting himself dead he
then notices a berber coming towards him
walking in a zigzag mike tries to warn
him about the landmine but the berber
imitates his actions seemingly making
fun of him mike tries to explain his
ordeal to the berber man but he insists
that mike must take the next step he
then takes mike's water flask and
disappears into the desert completely
dehydrated and desperate mike proceeds
to drink his piss when he notices a
little berber girl coming his way
bringing back his water flask she hands
it to mike and to his relief it's full
with water although the girl never
speaks using her toy soldiers she too
seemingly tells mike that he has to step
off the mine and move on mike tells her
that he can't move and asks the little
girl to fetch him his radio but the girl
doesn't understand
desperate mike gets too loud scaring the
girl away
soon the night falls and the temperature
starts to drop mike lights a fire to
keep himself warm he starts hearing
noises of wild animals he takes out his
phone and looks at the pictures of his
girlfriend to keep himself distracted he
finds a video from his girlfriend in the
video jenny tells mike that she is
waiting for him mike must win the war
and come back to her as soon as possible
mike begins to get emotional he is
afraid that he might never see his
girlfriend again tired of everything
happening to him he starts to fall
asleep but he snaps out of it to find
that the fire has died out he finds
himself surrounded by wild animals he
tries to scare them with his gun but
fails the animals drag tommy's body away
one animal starts to proceed towards him
but using his torchlight mike shoots the
animal with his gun the animal lands on
a land mine causing an explosion and
scaring the other animals away the
morning arrives and the same berber man
again drops by he tells mike that he is
very lucky that he has survived thus far
even after stepping on a landmine and
spending a night in the desert with wild
animals he once again suggests that mike
step forward but mike doesn't comply
mike tells him that he probably knows
the location of the mines as he always
walks in a pattern the berber responds
that he doesn't know where the landmines
are and he only walks in a zigzag
because it is safer than walking
straight mike again asks him to fetch
his radio the berber man finally agrees
and brings the radio back to mike and
then heads on his way mike checks his
watch and there's still 24 hours left
for the help to arrive he slowly starts
hallucinating mike sees tommy wake up
from his death the imaginary tommy
motivates mike and tells him that he
will get out of this alive the sun sets
again and mike starts to think about all
the mistakes he has made in his life he
starts regretting leaving his girlfriend
jenny alone and coming to the mission he
again finds himself surrounded by
animals mike aimlessly starts shooting
at them in the dark but the animals
still attack him he gets lost in his
thoughts as he fights off the wild
animals as the sun rises mike again
descends back to reality all the wild
animals that attacked him lay dead
around him despite being outnumbered he
managed to kill all of the animals
mike has been in that desert all alone
by himself with his foot over the mine
without moving for the last 45 hours he
then receives a communication from his
senior who informs him that the rescue
team is running late the senior asks him
if he can hold on for 17 hours
already way past his breaking point mike
replies that he cannot go any further
the major tells him that there is
someone who wants to talk to him mike
then hears the voice of jenny mike
frantically starts apologizing to her
for leaving her for messing everything
up and to destroying everything he
touches he then starts hallucinating and
sees jenny sitting on a couch in front
of him in the desert he tries to reach
her but starts losing strength
he begins to collapse when berber
catches him seemingly arriving out of
nowhere the man starts nursing mike's
wounds and tells him about the time when
he too once stepped on a mine which took
off his leg he tells mike that losing
his leg felt like he had lost everything
in his life however the pain of losing
his leg was all washed away when he met
his wife and had a daughter he says that
whatever happens in our life we must
keep moving on mike tells the man that
he indeed is lucky as his daughter who
brought him water is really beautiful
and has her father's smile the man tells
mike that he no longer has a daughter
she died in a mine explosion during one
of their father-daughter excursions to
dig out minds and replace them with tin
cans
mike listens dumbfounded the berber
tells him he's happy his daughter came
to meet mike but he really needs to move
on now
then he leaves
mike sees his daughter again but she
quickly fades away with the wind mike
starts to hallucinate again he sees his
abusive father who used to beat his
mother while he watched helplessly he
sees his terminally ill mother he also
sees the lovely times he spent with his
girlfriend
at that moment he hears on the radio
that the rescue team is passing and they
need him to make his exact location
known he picks up his flare but before
he gets to use it the terrorists from
before start shooting at him from over
the hill the shooting triggers a mine
explosion nearby which sends the flare
flying out of mike's hand and reach he
tries to fire back but he is too weak
but he remembers his girlfriend and uses
it as motivation mike then uses his gun
to shoot at the ground and triggers mine
explosions around him which creates sand
smoke shielding him from the enemy he
then quickly grabs his sniper rifle and
eliminates the terrorists with the
rescue team passing by the flare is
still out of reach mike remembers the
berber man's words that you have to keep
moving on he takes a leap of faith and
takes a step forward
nothing happens
there's no explosion he finds that the
mine he'd stepped on was in fact a tin
can probably placed there by the
berber's daughter when she was alive and
so the villager's words come to pass
this entire time the villager told him
that he could move forward with his life
and go back to his girlfriend he
reminded him that he can do it and the
only thing stopping him was fear mike is
relieved to be alive despite the
non-lethal gunshot wounds he sustained
in the standoff he starts bursting into
tears maybe he was relieved knowing the
fact that he will be saved or maybe he
was angry for not realizing the
correctness of the situation he then
shoots the flare and collapses on the
ground the rescue team finds him and he
returns home back home at the airport
jenny is waiting for him with happy
tears in her eyes even before hugging
her he drops to one knee like he has
done throughout different stages of his
life
he then proposes to her promising never
to leave her alone again
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out
thank you for watching